deuxième enjeu c'est l'enjeu des
transports et et je dirais de l'acè de
de de l'adaptation des conditions de
circulation particulièrement en
Île-de-France pendant les jeux je me
bornerai à indiquer deux points sur
l'offre de transport collectif puisque
c'est en principe c'est l'essentiel des
trafics c'est de l'ordre de 600000 à
800000 personnes par jour supplémentaire
venu pour les jeux spectateur titulaire
de billets on est dans un un schéma qui
est à peu près stabilisé avec un plan de
transport qui prévoira plus 15 % en
moyenne d'augmentation des capacités par
la RATP la SNCF et les autres opérateurs
de transport en Île-de-France ou en
France
entière toutes les zones pour lesquelles
on a des capacités de de de transport
qui vont être assez contraintes la zone
ouest avec le Parc des Princes le Roland
Garos où il y aura le même jour pendant
plusieurs journées deux intersessions
sur le Parc des Princes deux
intersessions sur le Roland Garos avec
des croisements de flux des gestions de
de de de de mobilité extrêmement
complexe à organiser des moyens
importants à mettre en terme de
facilitation pour rentrer et circuler
dans les dans les lieux de d'épreuve euh
un plan national de mobilité qui va être
mis en en place d'ici la fin mars au
plan national qui reprendra les les
données de chacun des sites et les et et
naturellement toutes les conditions
d'accès dans notre pays dans les
aéroports dans les gares euh les
renforces des moyens au postes de
contrôle frontalier et cetera et enfin
un un document qu'on appelle le TDM le
travel demand management qui est un
document de de gestion de la demande de
transport permettant d'informer les
Franciliens puisque là il s'agit d'Île
de France uniquement sur les les
conditions d'encombrement ou de les
difficultés d'accès sur certaines lignes
qui seront plus chargé que d'autres et
donc leur permettant de planifier leur
plan de déplacement domicile travail
notamment ou pour d'autres enjeux de
manière anticipée puis ensuite de
manière g en temps réel pendant les Jeux
donc ce dossier des transports mobilité
est considérable et euh il repose aussi
sur des priorités pour nous
d'accessibilité des transports et
naturellement de bonne information des
publics